[Musique]
quel est votre nom déjà
espen feu follet
je voudrais que nous levions notre verre
et que notre un pion à la santé de la
princesse christie
[Musique]
comment ça s'est passé
le roi et la reine ont avalé le posant
[Rires]
il n'existe aucun antidote
pas si vite vous connaissez le palais de
soria moria il a été bâti autour de la
source de l'eau de la vie il faut
absolument trouver ce palais
quoi je me suis fort et nous devons
trouver le palais de soria maria
comment as tu réussi à résister à ma
musique explique moi
l'orgueil la vie vous vous souvenez
comment on y va
est ce qu'on va trouver la princesse où
va la cible
nous allons pouvoir conquérir le monde
[Musique]
comment tu fais tu reste optimiste tout
le temps espen va ranger simple
[Musique]